en aussi plusieurs manifestations ont
lieu dans le pays pour dénoncer la
station de l'opposant alexeï navalni
placé en détention jusqu'au 15 février
au moins son équipe est appelée à se
rassembler dans 65 villes on retrouve à
moscou notre correspondant antoine
gayraud antoine des manifestations donc
à moscou et dans d'autres villes mais
tout à fait là je me trouve sur la place
pouchkine lieu de rassemblement de cette
manifestation une manifestation je
rappelle non autorisée par les autorités
alors ça fait un peu plus de deux heures
que je me trouve ici et au début surtout
beaucoup de journalistes et de police et
déjà plusieurs interpellations qui ont
eu lieu à des interpellations qui
continuent d'avoir lieu en ce moment
même derrière moi alors vous pouvez
peut-être voir beaucoup de gens brandir
des pancartes demandant la libération
d'alexei navali ou encore brandissant
des petits drapeaux en russe alors nous
sommes à moscou mais on vous l'avait
évoqué des manifestations ont eu lieu
dans pas moins de 65 villes à travers la
russie par exemple dans l'extrême orient
russe où il est maintenant plus tard les
matchs les manifestations sont terminées
à la demo stoke par exemple pas moins de
500 personnes ont été interpellées alors
pour vous donner un petit peu de
contexte c'est un manifestations ont été
organisées à la suite de l'appel
d'alexei navale et avec senna vanille
qui est revenu en russie
dimanche dernier il revenu d'allemagne
où il était soigné a passé une partie de
sa convalescence à la suite d'une
tentative d'empoisonnement présumés au
mois d'août dernier donc dimanche
dernier et quasiment sa descente de
l'avion il a été arrêté par les
autorités pour avoir violé sa période
probatoire qui courait jusqu'à la fin de
l'année 2020 dont vous pouvez voir
beaucoup d'animation derrière moi et ce
n'est que le début de cette de cette
manifestation qui a commencé il ya tout
juste officiellement touché 20 25
minutes
antoine merci à beaucoup pour toutes ces
précisions